the attack of a demon bear the
accidental eradication of all mutants
clones alternate realities and
resurrections deadpool's baby legs
here's the entire x-men timeline
explained
the franchise opens in 1944 at a
concentration camp a nazi scientist
notices a young prisoner manipulating
metal with his mind and becomes
instantly intrigued meanwhile in upstate
new york a young boy with telepathic
powers meets a young girl who can
shapeshift out of her blue scaly form
whenever she wants fast forward to 1962
and the young boy from the concentration
camp has become a nazi hunter and the
young telepath works with his face
swapping foster sister to study and find
more of their kind just like that the
franchise has established mystique as
well as magneto and professor xavier the
two pillars in the war for mutant
supremacy when magneto tracks down the
nazi that killed his family he discovers
that he's not only a mutant as well but
actively fighting for mutant supremacy
by trying to start a nuclear war between
the us and the ussr in the hopes of
wiping out anyone that isn't a mutant
magneto and xavier discover that the cia
has been hip to mutants as well and meet
a young scientist named hank mccoy who
is revealed to be a mutant too
another mutant already here why didn't
you say
say what
because you don't know
he's also a super genius who invented a
machine called cerebro that can be used
by a powerful telepath to track down
anyone on earth although they stop the
bad guy together magneto and xavier
become estranged and the team splits due
to differing views on how humanity
should coexist with mutants
after the events of first class wake the
world up to the existence of mutants one
man boliver trask hypothesizes the
destruction of all mankind at their hand
however trask has laughed out of most
academic circles for his beliefs and is
forced to form trask industries in 1967.
with the funds of a successful company
trask sets out to create an army of
robots known as sentinels designed to
identify and kill mutants in order to
make the sentinels a reality trask
experiments on mutants unfortunately for
him he chooses some of mystique's close
friends distance from magneto after a
falling out mystique seeks revenge on
trask she eventually tracks him down to
the paris peace conference being held
between the u.s and vietnamese military
leaders where he's pitching the concept
of mutants as a greater enemy to the
world leaders she assassinates trask but
is captured in the process the world
continues to live in fear of mutants and
the sentinel program continues its
development although it doesn't have its
fearless leader at the help it does have
mystique's shape-shifting dna
but back in the 1800s the audience meets
james howlett and victor creed two
half-brothers who ran away from home
when a groundskeeper kills hallett's
father the stress triggers james
mutation including claws made of bone
and a healing factor he kills the
groundskeeper who reveals himself to be
his birth father thomas logan before
running off into the night accompanied
by creed because of their healing factor
the two ageless beings fought in the
american civil war both world wars and
vietnam while in vietnam they're
sentenced to death when victor kills a
senior officer who tries to stop him
from sexually assaulting a woman of
course both men survive their execution
and are approached by major williams
striker the warden tells me that your
sentence was carried out by a firing
squad of 100 hours
how'd that go it tickled
stryker enlists them to join an elite
team of mutants as they set out on
morally questionable missions james
going by logan quickly gets tired of the
team and by 1979 when x-men origins
wolverine takes place has moved back to
canada he shacks up with a woman who
creed also known as sabretooth
eventually kills logan seeks revenge but
is quickly defeated he's then approached
by striker who offers to fuse the
skeleton with adamantium an
indestructible metal however when he
overhears striker talk about wiping his
memory in order to use him as his
personal muscle logan escapes now with
razor sharp claws he seeks revenge on
creed and striker by chasing them to an
island where they're experimenting on
mutants who are able to escape thanks to
the surprise arrival of professor x
however logan is tagged in the skull
with an adamantium bullet wiping his
memory
wolverine survives the next two decades
by drinking and generally being awesome
meanwhile professor xavier has opened a
school for mutants to learn to use their
powers and live safe from persecution
however when the us government suggests
a mutant registration act he and magneto
cross paths again it was a long time ago
mankind has evolved since then
yes
into us
having spent the years they've been
apart forming the mutant brotherhood
magneto leads a handful of villains
including mystique on a mission to use a
machine that will turn all humans into
mutants or simply kill them all he needs
are the power absorbing abilities of a
young woman who calls herself rogue
because her power can kill anyone she
touches rogue ran away from home and
found her way to wolverine when they're
attacked by sabertooth they're both
saved by xavier pupils cyclops and storm
who bring them both to the school it's
here that wolverine is introduced to
jean grey and the other mutants who make
up the x-men gray does her best to piece
together wolverine's past but he's more
interested in his fatherly relationship
with rogue so when she's captured by
magneto and his brotherhood he sets off
to find her with wolverine's help the
x-men chase magneto to liberty island in
new york city where they stop his evil
plan
after the events on liberty island
xavier gives logan a clue to his past he
finds his way to alkali lake where his
adamantium operation took place
meanwhile a mutant attempts to kill the
president of the united states in the
ensuing fear stryker convinces the
president to let him raid xavier's
school where some of the students get
abducted cyclops and professor x are
also captured as they attempt to
question an imprisoned magneto mystique
infiltrates the prison and helps magneto
escape he finds his way to the remaining
x-men that evaded the raid including
wolverine and jean grey he informs the
heroes that mystique discovered that
stryker has constructed a new cerebro
and plans to use his son who is a mutant
telepath to force xavier to identify and
kill every mutant on earth luckily the
base of this operation just so happens
to be the alkali lake facility where
wolverine was injected with adamantium
in an unlikely team-up magneto and
mystique join the x-men in stopping this
catastrophe before magneto flips the
script and tries to force professor x to
kill all the humans on earth instead
both he and stryker are foiled by the
x-men but only magneto and mystique
escape striker is left for dead as the
dam protecting the facility breaks
however as the x-men's jet tries to take
off the flood of water surrounds it jean
is forced to step outside and sacrifice
herself by using her powers to hold the
water back long enough for them to
escape
months later jean somehow returns
revealing that she had a mysterious dark
alter-ego inside her all along known as
the phoenix charles helped her repress
that part of her mind when he first took
her in but the traumatic event at alkali
lake awakened the phoenix she kills
cyclops just before wolverine and storm
discovered her meanwhile the company
reveals that it has developed a cure to
the mutant gene for people like rogue
who may want to be human voluntarily
magneto however sees this as the first
step in mutant extinction and reforms
the brotherhood their first stop is to
rescue an imprisoned mystique in the
ensuing fight they discovered that the
cure has already been weaponized just as
a cure dart is headed for magneto
mystique jumps in front of it
sacrificing her powers a kurt magneto
simply abandons her now that she's human
opting instead to take other powerful
mutant prisoners with him magneto
becomes aware of the phoenix and both he
and xavier confront her at the same time
magneto convinces her to join him after
she kills xavier although he has respect
for his old friend and rival he knows
that he can use the phoenix to stop the
cure the brotherhood and the x-men
including hank mccoy make a last stand
against the brotherhood to protect the
cure when the battle is over wolverine
is forced to kill gene and inject a cure
into magneto however it's implied the
cure doesn't work on him
killing gene doesn't do wolverine's
mental health any favor so he moves to
the yukon to live alone in the
wilderness while he tortures himself
with memories of the woman he loved
however he's brought out of the wild and
to japan by a rich businessman whose
life he saved during world war ii the
man ichiro who's dying and has used his
immense resources to develop technology
that would transfer wolverine's healing
factor into himself in an effort to
repay his life debt ichiro offers
wolverine death
but when the hero refuses the offer
ichiro hatches a scheme to take logan's
healing factor by force ichiro sends
assassins after his granddaughter mariko
knowing wolverine will help her
fortunately wolverine is able to stop
ichiro's master plan and regain his
powers after ichiro temporarily
suppressed them frankly the story
doesn't factor into the overall story of
the x-men too much other than in the
mid-credits scene in 2015 logan is
heading back to the united states while
at the airport he's confronted by
magneto who appears to have his powers
he doesn't want a fight though he's
there with charles xavier who is somehow
alive and looks the same despite his
body being disintegrated how is this
possible
as i told you a long time ago
you're not the only one with gifts
together they warn wolverine about an
imminent threat to mutants trask
industries
by the year 2023 the danger that xavier
and magneto teamed up to warn wolverine
about has come to fruition trask
industries managed to build and perfect
its sentinel army to hunt and kill all
mutants kitty pride has developed the
ability to send people's consciousnesses
back in time xavier storm and magneto
arrive and pitch a plan to use wolverine
in this way to stop the assassination of
bolivar trask here the x-men franchise
splits into a second timeline sent back
to his younger body in 1973 wolverine
essentially undoes the events of every
previous movie except first class after
finding a young charles xavier and
convincing him that this whole time
travel business is actually legit he's
persuaded to help rescue mystique from
her fate as a villainous assassin
wolverine mccoy and xavier enlist the
aid of quicksilver to bust magneto out
of jail knowing he'd be their best
chance to get through to her together
they foil mystique's first attempt to
kill trask but the ensuing fight
furthers the fear of mutants and
bolsters trask's chances to get his
sentinel program off the ground however
magneto takes control of the sentinels
and attempts to kill trask president
nixon and several other u.s leaders to
declare war on humanity he's stopped by
mystique an event that undoes the 2023
timeline and rescues future mutants from
sentinels
now that there's a new timeline of
events the x-men encounter a foe in 1983
that helps shape them as a team the
world's first and most powerful mutant
apocalypse wakes up after being entombed
alive in ancient egypt his method of
operation includes claiming four
horsemen to fight alongside him as he
destroys civilizations so that he may
rebuild them the way he sees fit in an
endeavor to start planet earth from
scratch he convinces a young storm angel
psylocke and magneto to join him as his
horsemen meanwhile new students scott
summers jean grey and kurt wagner arrive
at the mansion and develop a quick bond
when apocalypse figures out that there's
a mutant telepath as strong as xavier he
switches his mo and opts for total human
enslavement rather than destruction
after an attack on the x-mansion results
in its destruction scott gene and kurt
hatch a rescue mission with angel and
psylocke defeated magneto and storm turn
on apocalypse and the entire compliment
of x-men are able to defeat him together
they rebuild the x-mansion but magneto
refuses xavier's offer to stay and help
him teach mutants how to manage their
powers
in 1992 it's revealed that professor
xavier recruited jean grey to the school
when she was eight years old after
losing control of her powers leading to
the death of her mother her father
abandoned her out of fear forcing xavier
to put mental blocks in her mind to
shield her from trauma as he did in the
original timeline however when the x-men
are tasked with saving a space shuttle a
solar flare hits jean although she
survives she gains significantly
amplified powers which allows her to
break down those mental blocks gene
suffers ptsd that makes her powers
uncontrollable and fills her with rage
and pain eventually she has to fight the
x-men that are attempting to stop her
from hurting innocent people in the
ensuing battle she injures quicksilver
and kills mystique she seeks help from
magneto but is turned away when he sees
what a threat she is jean is ultimately
embraced by the dabari aliens whose
leader vuk explains that she's been
possessed by a cosmic force known as the
phoenix unfortunately the dabari turn on
gene as bux seeks to obtain her power
and enslave humanity the x-men win the
battle but it forces gene to explode in
a burst of phoenix energy the aftermath
sees mccoy taking over the school and
xavier retiring to paris to hang out
with magneto one day a phoenix figure
appears in the sky over them implying
that gene may not be dead after all
in the modern day of the new timeline
wade wilson is horribly disfigured but
given a powerful healing factor similar
to wolverine after agreeing to an
experimental treatment from the villain
ajax the mercenary's quest for revenge
gets the attention of the x-men who sent
colossus and negasonic teenage warhead
to convince him to join
when will he grow up and see benefits of
becoming x-men which benefits the
matching unitards the house that blows
up every few years
wilson under his new moniker of deadpool
refuses until vanessa the love of his
life is in danger and convinces the duo
to help him it's only after vanessa dies
that deadpool agrees to try being an
x-men team member on a trial basis
unfortunately he fills his trial period
by killing an alleged child abuser in a
desperate attempt to find purpose
deadpool meets a time traveler named
cable who tells him that a boy exists in
his timeline who goes on to become a
great super villain after convincing
cable that he doesn't need to
assassinate the boy to save his timeline
the duo team up and thwart the second
dystopian future nightmare of the
franchise once it's all over deadpool
gets his hand on the ability to time
travel rescues vanessa from dying
considers killing hitler and murders the
version of wade wilson that wolverine
fights in x-men origins in the original
timeline however given deadpool's meta
fourth wall breaking qualities it's hard
to know whether any of the events of his
movies are truly canonical to the larger
x-men timeline
due to its lack of visible crossover
characters and sparse references to
other points in the timeline it's a
little tricky to pinpoint when 2020's
the new mutants is happening luckily we
know that it happened between 2024 and
2027 after the other x movies but before
the events of logan when a tragic
catastrophe befalls her reservation
danielle danny moonstar wakes up in
milbury hospital dr cecilia reyes leads
dany to believe milbury is a treatment
facility for mutants with recently
emerged powers dany meets fellow teenage
patients rain sinclair ileana rasputin
sam guthrie and roberto de costa sadly
dr reyes is not who she claims to be
once her secret bosses order her to
execute dany she's forced to reveal
herself as a flunky for the mysterious
essex corporation with an endgame of
shaping young mutants into assassins
reign rescues danny and the rest of the
gang rallies in her defense but they're
no match for dr reyes's force field
powers the duplicitous doctor appears
victorious until she's eaten by a
manifestation of dany's powers known as
the demon bear once the team subdues the
demon bear the new mutants leave milbury
after the events of days of future past
logan's consciousness is transported
back into his 2023 body he finds himself
in the x-mansion not a dystopia he also
sees jean grey cyclops and everyone else
alive and well having no recollection of
the previous timeline it's implied that
wolverine unpacks the experience to
xavier but their celebration would not
last long logan brings the audience to
2029 where logan's healing powers are
fading it's also revealed that charles
xavier now senile accidentally killed
all the other x-men in some kind of
seizure episode a year prior only
wolverine is left alive and caring for
charles who he hopes to take to the
middle of the ocean where he won't be a
threat to anyone while living out the
rest of his days when i get back we're
going to get out of here
we're going to drive down the alapa
we're going to get ourselves a boat and
i'm gonna go live on the ocean
however when the duo discovers a little
girl that has similar powers to logan
based on experiments with his dna they
set off on a quest to get her to safety
in canada along the way they're attacked
by another clone of wolverine one with a
stronger healing factor than the aging
logan the clone kills xavier but
wolverine and the girl laura managed to
escape they reached the border of a safe
haven in canada only to be attacked by
laura's creators who want her back for
further experiments
logan injects himself with a serum that
temporarily restores his healing factor
allowing him to defeat both the soldiers
and his clone however the film ends with
the hero succumbing to his wounds and
being buried underneath the cross that
laura turns into an x check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
superhero franchises are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you